[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très très heureux
d'être là ce soir j'espère que vous
également
et donc je voulais commencer ce soir par
une question je veux savoir qui parmi
vous pensent que le bonheur au travail
est une chose aussi importante ou
compatibles que la performance en
entreprise c'est à dire si vous pensez
que le bonheur au travail est compatible
avec la performance en entreprise je
vous levez la main si vous pensez que ça
va ensemble
d'accords maintenant je veux que vous
leviez la main si vous pensez que ces
deux concepts ces deux notions sont
contradictoires en opposition voire
antinomiques vous dites non la
performance en entreprise et le bonheur
au travail sape ensemble je veux que
vous lever la main
ok donc tout le monde ici pense que le
bonheur au travail qu'est la performance
en entreprise vont ensemble d'accord
c'est très intéressant
donc je vais vous donnez moi ma
conception ma définition du bonheur au
travail
elle me vient de la poétesse américaine
my angel où elle disait le bonheur c'est
de s'aimer soi même
c'est d'aimer ce que l'on fait et c'est
aimé la façon dont on le fait et je
trouve ça particulièrement intéressant
qu'elle parle d' aimer ce que l'on fait
et surtout la manière dont on le fait et
vous allez comprendre par la suite dans
mes propos moi personnellement je vais
vous parler un peu de mon expérience
personnelle
j'ai à peu près une vingtaine d'années
d'expérience j'ai travaillé durant les
20 dernières années dans l'hôtellerie de
luxe j'ai travaillé dans la grande
distribution
j'ai travaillé dans l'aviation j'ai
travaillé dans le secteur du sport
j'étais coach j'ai travaillé dans le
secteur du vin sans boire de vin
je vous dis c'est la vérité donc j'ai
travaillé dans différents et divers
secteurs d'activité et j'ai eu diverses
expériences professionnelles et j'ai eu
le privilège et la chance de travailler
sur trois continents différents je suis
originaire du gabon donc j'ai travaillé
au gabon j'ai travaillé en france j'ai
travaillé au portugal et j'ai travaillé
aux états unis
et il ya une chose parmi tant d'autres
que j'ai constaté dans le monde de
l'entreprise
c'est que malheureusement
beaucoup de salariés dans les
entreprises n'aiment pas ce qu'il faut
vous vous souvenez de ce que manager loi
dit moi j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens
qui n'aimaient pas ce qu'il faisait et
il était là parce que il faut payer les
factures
et bien sûr qu'il faut payer les
certains d'entre vous ne travaillez pas
encore mais ceux qui ont des enfants et
des responsabilités on va payer les
factures donc la question n'est pas de
payer des factures vous savez quand vous
travaillez pour quelque chose que vous
aimez ça s'appelle la passion
vous ne comptez pas vos heures vous
pouvez travailler du matin au soir vous
n'êtes pas fatigué par contre quand vous
travaillez pour quelque chose que vous
n'aimez pas chaque minute chaque heure
est une torture et ça s'appelle la
dépression
je lisais ya quelques semaines
je lisais à quelques semaines un sondage
qui a été fait par l'institut opinionway
qu'est ce que ce sondage nous les se
sont désunis dit que 44 % des salariés
interrogés s'estiment est en détresse
psychologique
je répète le mot détresse psychologique
presque un salarié sur deux
le même sondage nous dit également que
le nombre le nombre des salariés en burn
out entre 2020 et 2021 a été multiplié
par deux pendant la pandémie
est aussi qu'on estime à environ 2
millions de salariés qui sont en berne
est sévère
je ne sais pas vous mais moi
personnellement
j'ignorais que le bénin était une
maladie professionnelle je pensais que
le bonheur tu étais une appellation
quand les personnes sont très stressés
en dix ans ok elles sont bonnes at mais
en fait non le bonne entente et une
maladie professionnelle
et ce sondage nous apprend également
qu'il existe deux types de bonne entente
il existe un burn-out on va dire
classique et il existe un bonheur sévère
est à peu près de deux millions de
salariés sont en bonnes à de sévères
donc c'est un chiffre assez élevé
et donc c'est vrai que quand on pense à
tous ces chiffres c'est un peu effrayant
et ça me fait on pense aussi par exemple
dans cette note cette étude l'étude dit
également que les salariés qui ont des
problèmes psychologiques c'est à dire
qu'ils ont besoin d'une assistance par
exemple d'un psychologue ou psychiatre
ce chiffre a considérablement accru
augmenté pendant la pandémie
et donc c'est vrai que je vous donne
tous ces chiffres moi par exemple
personnellement mon expérience
personnelle dans l'entreprise pour
laquelle je travaille pendant la
pandémie ils ont mis en place une
procédure pour avoir des consultations
gratuites psychologique pour les
salariés et j'ai plusieurs de mes
collègues qui ont consulté et qui se
sont confiés à moi qui m'ont dit que ça
les a aidés et j'ai aussi des proches
qui ont consulté pendant la pandémie et
je pense personnellement après cette
expérience je pense que c'est quelque
chose que toutes les entreprises
devraient mettre en place donc veiller à
la santé mentale des employés il existe
une procédure en place pour les
étudiants qui s'appelle le ch et six qui
sont trois consultations gratuites de 45
minutes avec un psychologue ou un
psychiatre
donc je pense que c'est très important
et c'est vrai que quand je vous donne
toutes ces informations
c'est vrai que ça paraît pas très joyeux
mais c'est la réalité de la vie et c'est
la réalité du monde de l'entreprise et
quand je pense à toutes ces informations
que je suis en train de vous donner ça
me fait penser à quelque chose que
socrate disait socrate disait toutes les
personnes que vous rencontrez passe par
des difficultés que vous n'imaginez pas
et socrates avait raison et je pense
également c'est quelque chose d'assez
vieux je sais pas si vous connaissez
henri salvador il avait une chanson
sûrement vos parents vos grands parents
henri salvador avait une chanson dans
les années 60 dans les titres et et le
travail c'est la santé
c'est assez ironique après tout les
chiffres que je vous ai donné et dans
cette chanson il dit quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est 1965 il dit les
prisonniers du boulot ne font pas de
vieux zoo
et je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
m'interroger
qu est-ce qu henri salvador dire en 2021
si 10 aces en 1965
c'est une très bonne question
et donc quand on pense c'est vrai toutes
ces choses là au niveau de l'entreprise
qu'est ce que les entreprises peuvent
faire
et donc je pense que par exemple dans le
monde de l'entreprise les entreprises
essayent de mettre en place par exemple
des procédures des solutions de
management je pense que la grande
majorité des entreprises je pense
veulent changer cette situation
parce que c'est pas c'est pas du bon
business dans le monde de l'entreprise
quand vous avez par exemple des gens qui
sont en arrêt maladie parce qu'il ya
aussi un chiffre aussi qui dit que les
personnes en arrêt maladie de longue
durée augmente les personnes qui sont à
la maison depuis six mois ou plus d'un
an pour des problèmes psychologiques les
entreprises n'ont pas intérêt à voir ce
genre de personne parce que la personne
ne travaille pas elle est payée n'est
pas productive donc c'est une des
raisons pour les pour laquelle les
entreprises mettent en place des
solutions de management des méthodes de
management connu par exemple comme six
sigma qui est une méthode de management
pour améliorer non seulement la qualité
mais aussi l'efficacité des du process
des produits et des services et aussi la
réduction des coûts vous avez une
méthode de management par exemple comme
line qui elle vit à une amélioration des
performances dans l'entreprise est aussi
une réduction des coûts
réduction des gaspillages
donc quand on a toutes ces informations
alors vous dites mais bruno c'est bien
toutes ces informations que tu lui
donnes lesquels la solution mais je vais
vous dire la vérité si moi j'avais la
solution je serais probablement le
ministre du travail où je serai le
consultant le plus riche au monde où je
serai où je serai je ne sais pas le
président de l'organisation
internationale du travail
et donc ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que pour moi la solution passe par un
équilibre
il faut qu'il y ait un équilibre entre
l'humanisme et le capitalisme qui est un
équilibre entre la productivité et
l'humanité et je pense que c'est par là
que passe la solution
et vous pouvez vous dire mais bruno
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme solution et
j'ai réfléchi quelles sont les solutions
alternatives
parce que je vous ai donné des méthodes
de management qui sont modernes mais
alors vous allez me dire mais bruno ses
méthodes de management ne résolvent pas
le problème les chiffres sont toujours
là évidemment ces méthodes de management
sont efficaces pour certaines choses
mais ne sont pas efficaces pour d'autres
choses donc j'ai essayé de voir quels
étaient les interactive et j'ai trouvé
une alternative qui s'appelle
le lot graphie la halle au gras fit un
look rassis pardon je sais pas si vous
avez déjà entendu pas de look racé c'est
une méthode de management qui est dit de
self management pourquoi parce qu'en
fait c'est une méthode de management qui
retire tout ce qui est manager qui
retire tout ce qui est fonction et qui
retire tout ce qui est rare chez donc en
fait au contraire des méthodes de
management verticale c'est à dire vous
avez un manager vous avez un agent de
maîtrise ou un chef d'équipé vous avez
l'équipe lola cratie c'est une méthode
horizontale c'est à dire tout le monde
est au même niveau
donc les responsabilités sont partagées
la prise de décision et collaborative et
donc l'entreprise la plus connue qui
pratique pratique dans le graphique
c'est la pause
je sais pas si vous connaissez
l'entreprise à postes c'est une
entreprise qui vend des chaussures et
c'est une entreprise en ligne et donc
ils pratiquent pratique depuis 2013
alors vous allez me dire pas de pad
management
pas de chef donc c'est parfait en fait
pas exactement
quand ils ont mis en place cette méthode
de management un an après 20 % des
salariés ont démissionné et en fait
c'est 20 % des salariés c'étaient les
managers parce que les managers ont été
rétrogradés en quelque sorte ils sont
devenus les collègues des personnes dont
il avait la responsabilité
donc au bout d'un an ils ont quitté
l'entreprise et ils ont dit cette
méthode de management pour nous elle est
confuse et elle est compliquée moi ce
que je pense et qu'il n'était pas très
content d'avoir perdu leurs pouvoirs de
manager
et donc vous avez par exemple aussi une
méthode c'est pas une méthode de
management mais vous avez par exemple
chez space x elon musk qui à sa
politique anti connard
noah sort ce policier qu'est ce que ça
veut dire je sais c'est pas moi c'est le
masque est en fait c'est une politique
qui l'a mis en place pour éviter que les
managers soient d'éboulis qui évite et
qui est du bowling donc en fait si
beaucoup d'emplois dans l'entreprise se
plaignent en fait les managers sont
virés pas immédiatement mais ils sont
convoqués et on les ramène à l'ordre
pourquoi il admet qu'il a expliqué lundi
non je veux qu'ils aient dents chez
space x je veux qu'il ya un
environnement où les gens viennent le
travail qu'il soit tranquille qu'ils
soient pas harcelés par leurs managers
donc c'est pas une méthode de management
c'est une politique c'est quelque chose
d'officiel
d'accord donc on a parlé de toutes ces
choses là
il ya une chose vraiment moi qui me
marque et qui est très forte
donc il ya quelque chose qui me marque
qui est très fort c'est ce que steve
jobs a dit donc on a parlé de toutes ces
thématiques de management mais steve
jobs l'a dit une chose très forte et
s'il ya une chose que je veux que vous
reteniez de tout ce que j'ai dit c'est
ça steve jobs l'a dit le management
s'est forcé les salariés à faire des
choses qu'ils n'ont pas envie mais il a
dit par contre le leadership s'est
inspiré les salariés à faire des choses
qu'ils n'auraient jamais pensé pouvoir
faire je vais répéter parce que je
trouve ça génial le leadership c'est
inspiré les salariés à faire des choses
qu'ils n'auraient jamais imaginé et je
pense que dans toutes les thématiques
dont on a parlé je pense que le
leadership c'est ça la solution plus que
les méthodes de management c'est
l'humain parce que le leadership c'est
communiquer avec la personne c'est
regarder la personne s'est inspiré la
personne à faire des choses et pas juste
donner des tâches à faire et donc pour
terminer
voltaire disait on juge un homme non pas
par ses réponses mais sa part ces
questions et donc je veux terminer en
vous laissant une question
est-ce que parmi vous il ya des leaders
ou bien vous êtes juste des futurs
peut-être manager et je veux que vous
vous posez cette question et cette
citation de gandhi c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours inspiré et qui
m'inspirent aujourd'hui c'est soyons des
agents du changement plutôt que
d'attendre que les politiques peut-être
face ou que votre voisin face soyez vous
les personnes qui allaient changer et le
leader n'a pas besoin d'avoir une
étiquette de manager ou de chef le
leader fait une attitude
donc je veux vous vous inspirez vous
encourager et bon courage et moi même à
être des leaders et apporter des
solutions de bien être là où nous sommes
dans nos entreprises dans nos facs merci
à tous merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]